الى باكستان الان التي شهدت يوما داميا
حيث نقلت وكاله رويترز عن قائد الشرطه
قوله ان واحدا 61 شخصا لقاه مصرعهم بينما
بلغ عدد الجرحى وسبعه 257 معظمها من رجال
الشرطه في انفجار داخل مسجدا يقع بالقرب
من مركز الشرطه بمدينه بشاور شماليه
البلاد رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني قال ان
الانفجار الجماعه عن هجوم الانتحاري تبنت
المسؤوله المسؤوليه عنه
باكستان
على تويتر
معنا الان من اسلام اباد سميره خان
الخبيره في شؤون الباكستانيه اهلا بك
سميره يعني هذا الهجوم الضخم الذي وقع في
باكستان ما الذي يقوله عن كل المقاربات
الامنيه وكذلك المقاربات العسكريه التي
تخددتها السلطات بحق حركه طالبان في
باكستان
اعتقدوا انه اذا ما عدنا الى سنه ونصف في
الزمن الى الوراء النيه كانت واضحه للغايه
بنسبه الى السلطات الامنيه والمؤسسات
الامنيه والعسكريه الباكستانيه اذا كان
هناك محاوله
للتفاوض مع حركه الطالبان في باكستان
ومحاوله لاعطائهم فرصه اخرى
للقاء السلاح والتقدم كارهابيين الى
السلطات والعوده الى باكستاني كي يعوش
كمادا كي يعيش كمدنين
وارادت السلطات ان تعطيهم فرصه لكي
يساهموا في صناعه السلام في بلدهم اذا
ولكن ما حصل هو ان الامور لم تجري على خير
ما يرام كان هناك طالب في هذه في
هذه المفاوضات وكان هناك مواجهه للسلطات
اا في باكستان
ولذلك اعتقد ان النتيجه هي ما
توقعناه
لكن لا شك بان هذه المفاوضات قد توصلت الى
تفاهمات هذا النار او ادت الى وقف النار
لفتره من الزمن مع حكومه عمران خان هل
يمكن القول بان جانب من المشكله سياسي بان
الحكومه الحاليه لم تبني على تفاهمات
سابقه باختصار سيده سميره
انجليزي انجليزي
اعتقد انها لم تكن مشكله لان ااا قياده
العسكريه على الحدود مع افغانستان
قالت في السابق
وتقدمت بتصريحات ولم يكن هناك مطالب بعدم
التفاوض
الاتفاقيات كانت موجوده ولكن المطالب
ازدادت يوما تلو الاخر من جانب طالب كان
هناك مطالبات بالنسبه الى القاده في
القبائل في تلك المنطقه بالاضافه الى
مطلبهم بان تترك القوات العسكريه المسلحه
كل المنطقه القبليه وذلك لم يكن ممكنا بعد
الانسحاب الامريكي من افغانستان